Nói tài lăng ngày 12 tháng 30 báo, một bí sĩ nước này đã bị thương nặng gió giấm phải miền khi tổn chào gần biên giới
cảm buổi chia. Người này là chúng sĩ T-Rapong, B-R-Hanty, bị thương ở trên trời khi đang bị tổn chào các biên giới khoảng 1 kí lời mẹ.
Fiat đông đến tà mòn thông. Pù nổ đã tạo ra hỗ giọng khoảng 1 mẹ.
Nói tài phân ngôn của lộ thái lan cho biết, khoảng miền được cài, nhằm vào bí sĩ thái lan.
Đông thời giao buộc cám buồn chia bi phạm thật hoặc nướng bản và tổn ước cấm miền sát thương.
Trong khi đó, việc cám buồn chia chưa đưa ra phản hội về sự việc mới nhất.
Nhưng trước đó, đã nhiều lần phủ nhận giao buộc cài miền cho rằng bí sĩ thái lan đã đi lệnh đường thật thật.
Và giấm phải miền còn xó lại từ thử trên trang.
Đây là vụ thứ tư trong vải tổn qua, bí sĩ thái lan bị thương giòn miền ở khu vực biên giới.
Vụ gần nhất sẽ giang emu chỉ thử tàm tài tình xí ra kẻ.
Hẹn bà bí sĩ bị thương.
Chứ đó quân hệ các buồn chia và thái lan xấu đi sau khi xung độ quân xước bùng phát ngày hai bí tư thống bây gần đến tàm tòm.
Sau đó, lan gióng giọc miền giới hiện 1 miếng bà người tìm mạm.
Sau năm ngày xóo trang, hai bên kỳ thọt thật nướng bản tại Malaysia.
Cám kết không chình khai thêm, hai điều trình được lượng giọc miền giới để vụ chi hoa bình.